president Trump signing the largest
economic stimulus bill a relief bill in
US history as states across the country
ramp up efforts to battle the fast
spread of coronavirus scientists are
scrambling to develop a vaccine and
therapeutics as we speak joining me
right now is South Carolina Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham he's chairman of
the Senate Judiciary Committee mr.
chairman it's always pleasure to see you
thanks very much for being here and you
as well have been wrangling with the
idea of whether or not to open the
economy during this pandemic but you say
you've spoken with dr. Fauci this
weekend and you want to err on the side
of caution yeah so I told the doctor
pouchy and theirs we're at war with the
virus there's a spring campaign plan a
summer campaign plan and a fall campaign
plan this will come back in the fall but
I think the heat in the summer will
lower transmissions the virus generally
doesn't do well in heat so here's what
dr. pouchy said to reopen the economy
you have to have a breakthrough in
testing we got to get testing back in
real time not four or five days so if
you got a County out there with no
infections the only way we can safely
open that county up for business is to
have a testing regime we don't have
today so I would wait they got warmer
before I tried to open up any parts of
the economy we need a risk assessment
next week and before we actually start
turning the economy on I think we need a
breakthrough in testing and we need the
support from the summer that to me would
be the cautious approach well what about
the president saying look the cure
cannot be worse than the virus I mean we
are talking about a recession at hand
we're already in a contraction and we're
expecting the economy to worsen no
business no profits no economic activity
whatsoever yeah that's the balance we're
trying to make to try to create a bump
in the economy you don't want to create
create a spike in the disease the
president said safety first economic
rebounding second this package is going
to be a lifeline to people out of work
it's going to be a lifeline to
businesses who are who have no revenue
so this bill we passed is going to help
people for a couple of months the summer
will be here before you know it in the
spring
what I would do is ramp up my medical
supplies I try to focus on testing
antibiotics and therapies to destroy the
disease in the fall so this risk
assessment that's coming out next week
about what parts of the economy you may
reopen I don't think you can safely open
up any part of the economy until we have
more testing let me let me ask you about
this stimulus bill this relief package
if you will it's more of a relief
package than anything else you had issue
with the loophole around unemployment
basically giving money to people to stay
at home explain that for us senator okay
so if you make $15 an hour for a 40-hour
week that's 600 dollars a week my goal
was to make sure that in the
unemployment part of the package we made
you hold that you're laid off no fault
to your own you'd get $600 a week what
we did in the package is we plussed up
unemployment benefits so you'll get 926
dollars a week if you live in South
Carolina we increased your pay by 50%
that's going to make it harder to get
people back into the workforce it's
going to incentivize people not to go
back into the workforce and it's going
to make it harder for people to hire new
employees if you're Amazon and Walmart
the hourly wage not to work in South
Carolina is 23 dollars and 14 cents I'm
all for helping people how did this
happen they tell us at the state level
it would take six to eight months to
create a computer program to pay the
difference between the state
unemployment benefit in your actual age
so what do we do we just put six hundred
dollars on top of it so we took a $1,500
$15 an hour employee who was making six
hundred dollars working we're gonna pay
them nine hundred twenty six dollars in
South Carolina not to work we need to
fix that how are you gonna fix it get
some state to figure software that can
pay you the difference between the
maximum benefit per week of three twenty
six and six hundred dollars they tell me
that can't be done we sent two men to
the moon now Steven minuchin this is not
his fault we have a six hundred dollar
federal benefit on top of the state
benefit we have a situation where people
getting a hundred percent pay raise not
to work we have got to fix that some
smart person needs develop software that
can pay your actual wages not increase
your wages and unemployment well take
take us behind the curtain and to tell
us how this all shook out senator
because Nancy Pelosi said she did
jujitsu on this relief bill to get it
where it needs to be and this morning
this weekend she is saying that the
president is fiddling around while
people are dying senator know what she
said she's blaming the president the
United States for people dying because
of the way he's led the country that's
the most shameful disgusting statement
by any politician in modern history let
me tell you we've seen the best of
America from our citizens helping each
other
delivering groceries having special
shopping hours for sent senior citizens
she's the first politician to blame
another politician for people dying this
is the same Speaker of the House who
held up the bill in the Senate four days
because she wanted same-day voting she
wanted carbon neutrality for the
airlines she wanted 75 million dollars
for the Endowment for the Humanities and
25 million dollars for the Kennedy
Center she is the one that held up the
package in the Senate four days to get
the green New Deal put in a recovery
package so it's the most shameful
disgusting thing I've heard yet and it
needs to stop
well you you agree to send 25 million
dollars to the Kennedy Center you put
that in a so-called really oh because
she wouldn't let them yeah so she put a
gun to her head and said we will not get
this through the house until you put
twenty five million dollars with a
Kennedy Center she wanted the entire new
grid a new Green Deal in the package she
wanted to have every airline has to be
carbon neutral by 2025 what the hell's
that got to do with saving lives were
affected by the coronavirus she had the
entire green New Deal in the package we
took most of the garbage out but for her
to blame this president for causing loss
of life after she held up the relief
package four days to get a liberal
special-interest shopping list in the
bill is pretty disgusting it's
absolutely extraordinary senator it's
good to see this money thanks very much
for joining me